we're on problem seven and they drew
this graph so i guess i'll draw it as
well
that's the x-axis
that's the y-axis
let's see they draw off
one two
and they draw
one two three
and then the graph
goes through
here and then curves up like that and
actually goes through this point right
there
it goes through y is equal to three at
least the way they drew it on the graph
before
when x equals one-half y is equal to two
so they're saying that this point right
here
is one-half
comma two
fair enough
and when x is equal to one y is equal to
one so they're saying at this point
right here put in a different color just
to not make it too confusing that point
right there is the point one comma one
the graph is symmetrical with respect to
the vertical line at x equals 2 so that
means that it's a mirror image around
that vertical line
according to the graph when x is equal
to 3 y should be equal to
so when x is equal to three
we are one away from there
from the line x is equal to two or what
the line is a mirror image right so when
we were one to the left of it
that's when x is equal to one and we
learned y is equal to one so if we're
one to the right and this is symmetric
around this line
then we're going to have the same height
right
so when we're one to the left the height
was one when we're one to the right the
height will should also be one so this
should be the point three comma one so
the choice is e
all that other information was kind of a
waste of time
next problem
problem eight
when one tenth percent of five thousand
so one tenth
percent
so just to get i always like to get
these into decimals one tenth percent
that equals this divided by a hundred so
it's one over a thousand so it's
0.001
so 0.01 times 5 000
is subtracted from one tenth of 5 000.
the difference is okay so they're saying
they're saying
one tenth
five thousand minus one thousandth
of five thousand right that's one tenth
of a percent is one thousand
so you get five hundred
minus five
right
and that's 495
which is choice
d
problem nine
which of the following is the value of
the square root
of
the cube root
of let's see zero point and how many
zeros do they have one two three four
one two three
four
six four
okay so there's how many total numbers
are behind the dust point one two three
four five six
so it's cube root so some number times
itself three times is equal to 0.0064
and you know whenever you multiply
decimals you add up the number of spots
behind the decimal point if i have two
numbers that have two numbers to the
right of the decimal point and i
multiply them i end up with 4.
so if you just wanted to eyeball this
you say well first of all what number to
the third power is equal to 64.
well 4 to the third power is equal to 64
right it's equal to 16 times 4
which is equal to 64.
so this should have a 4 someplace in it
you know it should look like a 4 it's
going to be a decimal number because
obviously the numbers gotten smaller
every time i
when i took the exponents of this number
and the clue is how many decimal points
are there behind the or how many places
are there behind the decimal one two
three four five six
and i'm multiplying whatever this number
is times itself three times
so in order to get six digits behind the
decimal point that original number
probably has two digits behind the
decimal point so my initial kind of
estimation is going to be
it's going to have a 4 in it it's going
to be 0.04
and i'm pretty sure i'm right here
because well you could try it out for
yourself but 0.04 times
0.04 you say oh 4 times 4 is 16 but i'm
going to have 2 spaces behind i'm going
to have now 1 2 3 4 spaces behind the
decimal point
and then if you multiply that times .04
4 times 16 is 64.
and now i'm going to have 1 2 3 4 5 6
bases behind the decimal point
and i get
.00064 which is exactly there so the
problem now boils down to square root of
0.04
and use the exact same logic that is
equal to 0.2 and try to square 0.2
you'll get .04 right 0.2 times 0.2 you
say 2 times 2 is 4 and i have 1 2 spaces
behind the decimal point so 1 2 spaces
behind the decimal point
0.04 and that's
d
problem 10
raffle tickets numbered consecutively
from
101 through 350 are placed in a box 101
through 350
are placed in a box what is the
probability that a ticket selected at
random will have a number with a
hundreds digit of two
so we're essentially saying out of this
collection how many of them have a
hundredth digit of two
so essentially it's going to be anything
from 200
to two
ninety nine
well that's essentially a hundred digits
right
that's uh that's those are a hundred
numbers that have a hundred digit of two
right think about it from two hundred
two hundred by itself would be one from
200 to 1 would be 2
so
200 to anything would be that anything
plus 1. so there's
there's a hundred numbers
that satisfy it
100 numbers that satisfy it and then how
many numbers are we picking from
well if it was from 100 to 350 would be
250 numbers but since it's from 101 to
350 we're picking from a pool of
right 350 minus 101 we're picking from a
pool of 249
numbers
right 249 numbers although
let me think about that
this is a hundredth digit right we're
picking from a pool of
i just want to make sure if it was 101
to 2
we would be to 102 we'd be picking from
a pool of
right we're picking from a pool of 249
numbers
so the odds of getting one with a 2
having a number with a 2 in the hundreds
digit will be 100
over
249.
so that is
choice e
i'm just making sure that i haven't
made a
actually no i'm going to take that back
because how many digits if i said from
300 to 350 that's 51 digits if i say 101
to 350 that's not 249 digits
made a mistake that's because you're
including 101 right
so
it would actually be
250 digits sorry it's 250 numbers we're
picking from a bag of 250 numbers think
about it if i if it was from 101 and
these you have to make sure you get your
kind of boundaries right on these if we
said from 101 to 105
how many are this this would be 101 102
103 104 and 105. so it's one two three
four five it's five digits so it's 105
minus 101 plus one
so similarly the bag that the number of
digits we can pick from is going to be
minus 101 plus 1 which is equal to 250.
so anyway
out of the bag of 200 of 250 100 numbers
satisfy it so we're going to have 100
and 250 chance of picking the right
number and if we divide the top and the
bottom by 50 right that's the greatest
common divisor we get 2 over 5. and that
is choice a
and i got a little
cautious because i saw that they had all
these choices that were really close to
each other and they all seem to test
like choices d and e they all seem to
test whether you got the boundaries
right whether you really counted the
pool correctly and whether you really
counted the number of digits correctly
and i always have to go through the
exercise of let me make sure whether or
not i need to count 101 whether i can
just subtract them or whether it's
subtractions plus one i always have to
clarify that in my own brain maybe that
was easier for you
question 11.
question 11
on monday a person mailed eight packages
weighing an average
of twelve and three eight pounds
twelve and three eight pounds
and on tuesday four packages so this is
eight
weighed that much
and on tuesday four packages
weighing an average of fifteen and one
fourth pounds what was the average
weight in pounds of all packages the
person mailed on both days so you
essentially have to take the sum of the
weights of all of them and divide by the
total right so what's the sum of the
weights of all of them so the sum of the
weights of these eight packages we know
they're average
so the sum of the weights are going to
be 8
times 12 and 3 8
times 12
and 3 8.
that's the sum of all of these
plus 4 times the weight of these plus 4
times 15 and 1 4
and we're going to divide that by the
total number of packages divided by
12.
so this is equal to let's see
what's 8 times 12 8 times 12 is
and what's 8 times 3 8 so it's 96 plus 3
right you could view 12 and 3 8 is 12
plus 3 8. so that's i kind of just did a
distributive property there you could
turn this into an improper fraction if
that's easier
and then plus what's 4 times 15 it's 60
right and then 4 times 1 4 is 1
all that over 12. and so we have
plus 61
all of that over 12
which is equal to
over 12.
let's see does 12 go into 160 12 times
12 is
144 let me think about this so let me
just divide it by top and bottom by four
so you get 40
over
three
40 over three and let's see all of the
answers they have in terms of fractions
so 3 goes into 40 how many times
it goes into 13 right 13 times 3 is 39
so it's 13 with remainder 1. so 13 and
one third time so a is the answer
so the average of all of the packages on
both days are 13 and 1 3 pounds
see in the next video